nous allons débuter par l'agenda de
cette semaine demain aura lieu le bureau
politique à 18 heures et jeudi et
vendredi les journées parlementaires à
divonne les bains en présence de laurent
wauquiez
voilà pour l'agenda de la semaine nous
allons passer donc un point plus sur les
annonces fiscales qui ont été faites
notamment avec les déclarations de
christophe castaner et de la mise de la
culture françoise nyssen
alors est ce que ces annonces masque de
nouveau de nouveaux impôts qui seront
une forme d'acharnement sur les milieux
de cordes et les grands oubliés de la
politique d' emmanuel macron avec
notamment l'extension de la redevance
télévisuelle sur l'ensemble des
contribuables et la hausse de la
fiscalité sur les successions
alors c'est une politique qui est
catastrophique pour le pouvoir d'achat
des français
on s'oriente de plus en plus vers une
politique qui se résume à un acharnement
fiscales notamment sur sur les ménages
et les milieux de cordée alors le
pouvoir d'achat des français au premier
semestre
rappelons quand même qu'il ya une baisse
de 0,6 pour cent qui est la plus forte
baisse depuis 2012 et nous sommes quand
même le pays qui détient le record des
prélèvements obligatoires
or cette politique fiscale du
gouvernement et ressemble de plus en
plus à une politique est une aberration
sur le plan économique alors hausse des
impôts mais également en hausse des
taxes carburants gazole fioul
tout cela va encore venir diminuer le
pouvoir d'achat des français et donc la
consommation et la croissance ça aura
forcément un impact négatif alors par
cette politique emmanuel macron démontre
qu'il est bien l'héritier de françois
hollande le ministre de françois
hollande devenu président de la
république garde les vieilles recettes
socialiste en matière fiscale celles qui
n'ont jamais apporté de résultats
bon et qui n'ont jamais permis de
redresser l'économie du pays
voilà le matraquage fiscal des français
ne permettra ni de relancer la
consommation
ni la croissance et donc ne permettra
pas de relancer l'emploi le gouvernement
par ses annonces va encore dans le mur
et n'obtiendra pas les résultats que
nous attendons avec avec impatience et
qu'ils sont définitivement pas au rendez
vous oui charlie ya en effet les
déclarations récentes de plusieurs
ministres démontre cette passion
dévorante qui emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement exerce sur l'argent des
autres
la confisquer les plaines vous avez
évidemment su à quel point les retraités
de notre pays sont matraquer fiscalement
vous avez vu aussi toutes ses impôts et
toutes ces taxes qui augmentent qui se
multiplient et qui malheureusement se
confirme et à tout cela et à tout ce que
nous avons déjà subi
nous ajoutons désormais dans le cadre
d'une confusion gouvernementale
des déclarations qui montrent que ce
n'est pas fini et que entre une
redevance qui serait payée par ceux qui
n'ont pas la télévision
et puis l'impôt sur les successions qui
se verrait substantiellement augmenté et
revisité en réalité c'est une obsession
fiscale qui celle des membres du
gouvernement et des manuels macron qui
devient véritablement préoccupante pour
tous les contribuables
alors tout cela ajouté au prélèvement à
la source qui s'avère être pour chacun
d'entre nous un océan de complexité eh
bien j'avais il ya il existe des paradis
fiscaux bien je crois que emmanuel
macron est en train de faire entrer la
france dans les portes de l'enfer fiscal
et cet acharnement comme tu l'as dit
lidia cet acharnement pour les milieux
de cordée et pour tous les contribuables
qui pourtant travail qui ont mérité
notamment leur retraite
tous ceux qui ne peuvent plus se
défendre et qui ont pourtant
respecter les règles du jeu de la
république française c'est insupportable
et nous voulions aujourd'hui avec lydia
vous dire à quel point effectivement
nous alertons les français sûreté sur
cet acharnement fiscal dont fait
manifestement proche de plus en plus le
gouvernement
il ya sur un tout autre sujet alors on
va évoquer la sphère benalla puisque la
commission d' enquête du sénat va se
réunir et bas et va le recevoir
donc contrairement à ce qui a pu être
dit la sphère benalla semble devenir
véritablement une affaire d'état il est
quand même étonnant de voir autant
d'interventions de la part de ministres
et même du président qui a quand même
appelé le président du sénat gérard
larcher en faisant fi de toutes les
règles élémentaires et notamment celle
de la séparation de pouvoirs pour
évoquer cette affaire qui concernerait a
priori d'après ce que dit monsieur
castaner un simple bagagistes mais qu'a
fait ce simple bagagistes pour faire à
ce point trembler le gouvernement et
surtout que faisait t-il réellement
auprès d' emmanuel macron personne ne le
connaît d'après ce que disent les uns et
les autres et pourtant ils bénéficient
d'une impunité d'une protection qui
dépasse l'entendement
pourquoi le gouvernement emmanuel macron
tremblent autant de vent devant cette
affaire après avoir saboté la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale après
avoir fait des déclarations qui qui sont
totalement préoccupante et qui démontre
une certaine forme de panique de la part
du gouvernement et des maquereaux nist
aujourd'hui c'est la commission d'
enquête du sénat qui a attaqué et même
philippe bas le sénateur philippe bas
qui a été insulté par par alexandre
benalla comment peut-il se permettre
d'insulter fihri base sans être assuré
d'avoir une certaine protection
donc véritablement la pression et coup
de fil du président sont sont très très
inquiétant parce que ça relève purement
et simplement d'une atteinte intolérable
à la séparation des pouvoirs et il faut
rappeler quand même que c'est grâce à la
commission d' enquête du sénat qui est
la dernière chance pour les français de
savoir véritablement ce qui se cache
derrière cette affaire benalla et de
faire éclater la vérité sur sur sur les
agissements et les protections et
dissimulation au sommet du pouvoir
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire sur sur
cette affaire benalla geoffroy si tu
veux ajouter quelque chose je ne te
contredire ait pas effectivement un
président de la république qui appelle
le président d'une assemblée législative
pour se plaindre un ministre de la
république monsieur castaner qui
considère que les sénateurs veulent
menacé la république
et puis une garde des sceaux qui ce week
end d'un ton très professoral se permet
de prodiguer un enseignement pédagogique
particulièrement orientées alors que son
rôle
précisément commission de la justice et
de rester en dehors et au dessus de tout
cela et donc il y à une pression qui est
exercée par l'exécutif sur le pouvoir
législatif qui est insupportable et qui
surtout indigne d'une démocratie moderne
celle là même que le président appelait
prétendument de ses voeux et donc nous
avons lu la constitution
elle est très claire l'article 51 2 de
la constitution rappelle bien qu'il
existe et ce depuis 2008 les commission
denquête qui peuvent parfaitement
recueillir des informations
c'est leur droit le plus strict et c'est
notamment aussi leurs droits parce que
c'est le devoir de chacun notamment du
gouvernement de dire la vérité aux
français
les français ont le droit à la vérité et
donc nous appelons aujourd'hui le
gouvernement le pouvoir exécutif
emmanuel macron lui-même à faire preuve
de décence
plutôt que de faire preuve d'ingérence
voici ce que nous voulions vous dire en
introduction de ce point presse
et maintenant la parole est à vous pour
les questions éventuelles je voulais
savoir ce qu'il y avait à l'ordre du
jour demain du bureau politique est ce
que le cas d'aig nerfs va être évoqué au
bureau politique de demain nous allons
évoquer l'élection des jeunes
républicains et vous aurez à l'issue de
ce bureau politique une communication
sur l'organisation des élections des
jeunes république
mais tous les deux en tant que porte
parole du parti est ce qu'un candidat à
la présidence des jeunes républicains
qui prône l'union des droites en
présence notamment du porte parole du
rassemblement national et qui s'inscrit
à l'école de formation de marion
maréchal a toute sa place pour vous
toujours au sein du parti
par respect pour le bureau politique
parce qu'une formation politique c'est
aussi un organe collectif je vous dis
que demain enfin lydia viens de vous
dire que demain nous fixons rions
ensemble les modalités d'élection du
président des jeunes républicains après
la démocratie fera son oeuvre
chacun pourra choisir un ou une
candidate selon la ligne qui est la
sienne
notre ligne est évidemment et celle de
laurent wauquiez n'a jamais été celle
d'une alliance avec le front national
nous l'avons dit je crois ici à peu près
huit cent quarante quatre fois donc on
peut le faire
huit cent quarante cinquième fois notre
philosophie d'action elle est très
claire et évidemment nous souhaitons que
tous ceux qui un jour des
responsabilités au sein des républicains
soient sur la même ligne le ministre de
l'éducation annonce la suppression de
1800 postes dans l'éducation nationale
tout en disant que la priorité ce sera
le pouvoir d'achat des profs finalement
moins de profs mieux payés parce que
c'est pas une mesure totalement
sarkozyste
cette annonce ressemble plutôt je trouve
un bricolage et il est vrai qu'on a un
peu du mal à voir quelle est la vision
globale en fait du gouvernement sur sur
la fonction publique et la réforme de la
fonction publique comme je le disais la
france elle détient le record des
dépenses publiques et record des
prélèvements obligatoires aux
républicains nous nous ce que nous
proposons c'est de revoir en profondeur
la faune le fonctionnement de réformer
en profondeur la fonction publique avec
proposition qui a été faite par laurent
wauquiez c'est un passage à 39 heures
pour les fonctionnaires avec une
revalorisation salariale tout en
renforçant le régalien et en protégeant
l'hôpital pour le moment ça ressemble à
véritablement à du bricolage l'objectif
d' emmanuel macron sa promesse était
cinquante mille fonctionnaires en moins
on en est loin
l'objectif ne sera pas tenue à 7 à ce
rythme là moi je me demande comment
comment l'éducation nationale et jean
marie blanque air va réussir à dédoubler
les classes tout en réduisant le nombre
de professeurs il ya quelque part une
équation qui est un petit peu compliqué
c'est sans doute dû en même temps j'en
reviens ou bp de demain je crois savoir
que jeudi dernier a été arrêté le nombre
d'adhérents
à jour de cotisation je voudrais savoir
combien ils sont pour pouvoir voter à
cette élection de jeunes et la deuxième
question savoir si les règles de
parrainage telle qu'elle était en
vigueur jusqu'à leur s'appliquait
toujours pour cette élection
votre question
enfin le dernier volet votre question
porte sur les jeunes spécifiquement il
ça en réalité on pourra vous répondre
que demain à l'issue du bureau politique
puisque ce seront les propositions de
laurence arribagé et d'alexandre vincent
dès qu'ils seront étudiées et surtout
voter demain en bureau politique donc je
ne peux pas vous répondre avant le
bureau politique sur le nombre
d'adhérents à jour de cotisation je sais
que je vois en tant que délégué de
circonscription dans dans la
circonscription que j'anime j'ai vu
beaucoup d'adhésions beaucoup de
réadhésion beaucoup d'adhésions nouvelle
je voudrais le chiffre de ma
circonscription mais je pense qu'ils
n'intéressent pas l'ensemble du
territoire
en revanche on vous consolidera les
chiffres dans les tout prochains jours
je pense que tout cela sera officialisé
très rapidement d'accord sur un autre
sujet valérie pécresse s'est ému ce
matin du vote de certains députés de
deux eurodéputés verts contre la la
résolution est même contrôleur ban
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire quand
valérie pécresse dit que la l1 vite se
sont partis et les républicains a
retrouvé son adn politique qui part et
qui a priori serait perdue par ce vote
contre la résolution notamment de brice
hortefeux n'a pas non pardon qui savent
de la nuit noire nous tant pendant
quatre sur le vote de la semaine
dernière je crois qu'il démontre à quel
point la droite c'est être diverses
qu'elle incarne plusieurs sensibilités
et à quel point aussi ceux qui avaient
tenté la caricature et nous pourrons
manifestement pas le faire le vote
n'était le vote du ppe d'ailleurs
n'était pas ce qui ne concerne pas que
les républicains cette aventure du ppe
n'étant rien une condamnation de la
politique migratoire de victor et à
titre personnel
et là je ne représente pas les
républicains mais seulement mon propre
vote en tant que député au parlement
européen
si j'ai fait le choix de l'abstention
c'est précisément parce que le rapport
qui nous a été présentée ne portait pas
sur la politique migratoire de mesures
bâle c'était un rapport d'une députée
européenne néerlandaise écologistes qui
portaient sur le respect ou non de
l'état droit par le gouvernement ou et
je crois que nous devons être rigoureux
par respect pour les français et à
partir du moment où ce rapport ne
portait pas sur la politique migratoire
et donc c'est pour ça que le vote
n'avait rien à voir avec la politique
migratoire de monsieur urban et notre
souhait n'est pas de la condamner mais
portait sur le rapport à l'état de droit
à partir du moment où nous avons été
déçus à quelques-uns des déclarations
même de monsieur urban qui est venu
s'expliquer devant le groupe ppe et bien
nous avons fait le choix de nous
abstenir
et je crois que la force la droite c'est
aussi cette diversité
la force de la droite c'est aussi de
savoir répondre aux questions et ne pas
se laisser caricaturer
je voulais revenir sur les modalités
pour l'élection du président des jeunes
et leurs modalités on est d'accord ce
sera des modalités uniquement technique
jean nombre de parrainages constitution
d'une liste etc etc la question de la
défense de certaines valeurs de l air à
savoir pas d'alliance pas de fusion des
droites ça ça ne fait pas partie des
modalités qui seront arrêtées pour
éventuellement empêcher monsieur
tesnière de se présenter demain je
comprends votre impatience mais vous
aurez l'ensemble des informations demain
après le bureau politique est encore une
fois nous avons toujours été très clair
sur la ligne politique est depuis
longtemps que ce soit nicolas sarkozy
jacques chirac ou laurent wauquiez
il n'y aura pas d'alliance avec
l'extrême droite
donc les républicains sont absolument
claires et dans et dans la constance sur
ce point là et concernant les jeunes je
vous rappelle que pour le moment il est
candidat à la candidature
et pour l'ensemble des modalités vous
les aurez demain donc soyez fait preuve
d'un peu de patience ce n'est que dans
quelques heures que vous aurez à
l'ensemble des informations
pardon je vais encore vous embêter vous
dites on va discuter des modalités de
l'élection et la démocratie fera son
voir le reste fera son oeuvre jusque là
effectivement vous avez été clair là
dessus ce qui prenait une alliance avec
le front national aujourd'hui
rassemblement national était exclu du
parti
pourquoi l'exclusion d'eric tonnerre
n'est pas l'ordre du jour demain la
personne dont vous parlez n'a
strictement aucune responsabilité au
sein des républicains elle a
manifestement grâce à vous une forte
existence médiatique c'est votre
responsabilité
en tout cas elle n'est pas membre du
bureau politique
elle n'est pas membre des instances
dirigeantes elle n'est pas porte parole
elle n'exprime en rien la volonté la
ligne la stratégie est la philosophie de
notre famille politique nous qui pouvons
effectivement incarner notre famille
politique
nous avons toujours été très clair donc
vous pouvez aller chercher un militant
un jour de cotisation en mal d'existence
médiatique
vous pouvez le faire exister
médiatiquement si vous le souhaitez
encore une fois c'est votre choix et
c'est votre libre responsabilité nous
nous préférons nous concentrer sur des
modalités démocratique afin qu'il y ait
un ou une jeune qui démocratiquement
émergent pour incarner le renouvellement
au sein de notre famille politique et
évidemment sur les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et sur lesquels nous n'avons
jamais ou l'avouerez transiger cas ça
vous laisse bouche bée désormais malgré
cette passion que vous avez pour les
jeunes républicains c'est une bonne
nouvelle de votre part séquence
nostalgie séquence nostalgie pour relire
beaumont
écoutez c'est un peu dans la continuité
de ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale c'est c'est une façon de
mettre à mal le travail de cette
commission denquête et ça démontre
encore une fois qu'il ya quelque chose
qui dérange voir une vérité que l'on ne
veut pas voir éclater et on se demande
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à cacher pour pour
manoeuvrer à ce point pour pour rendre
le travail de cette commission denquête
plus plus difficile